and joining us right now here on the
mercedes-benz vans phone line is the
head coach of ole miss football getting
ready to take on the sixth ranked baylor
bears in the sugar bowl on new year's
day lane kiffin here how are you doing
coach
great rich thanks for having me there
you got it uh it's been a long time
since you and i spoke so i just figured
i'd reach out because i i love what
you're doing down there in mississippi
you know appreciate it yeah it's been a
fun year we got some special players and
led by the quarterback this awesome
player but awesome kids so
i think
something like second sugar bowl in 50
years here and first 10 win regular
season in his school history so it's
just really cool to be around these kids
and coaches and be part of that
so yeah playing baylor uh on in that
game it's obviously a a huge game uh i'd
love to get your your sense of what is
going on what what is your life like
right now because the early signing
period just happened and you got a bowl
game that your quarterback is gonna play
in right matt corral's playing in this
sugar bowl game he's gonna do it yeah
we've been fortunate we've got no
opt-outs and they're all playing so
it's great okay and so are you have you
been hitting the road recruiting and
things like that i wonder what what is
what is the life of a big time college
football coach like
uh it right around now in the world of
early signing periods and nils and
transfer portals and things like that
yeah it used to be you could
you know singularly focus really on the
bowl game within the early signing
period we were out doing that then it
went dead after that but
now you have this
portal
situation i guess
and
it would be
really like for those swimming with nfl
like you have free agency
there's not like a time window on it so
anybody can go in whenever they want and
here's where it gets really tricky now
with nil and people
saying when you come here you're going
to get this much money and they tell
these kids all this stuff
so here's a free agent contract but
there's no contract so you don't really
know if you're going to get the money
when these people say it
so
you can figure out that's a pretty
difficult situation
and so uh
do you have like a uh uh i guess
somebody who keeps it all straight for
you to say like this is what the
transfer portal looks like this is what
our regular recruiting process looks
like and this is how much we have left
for anybody who's in the transfer portal
and then you have to identify who might
be interested in you in the transfer
portal and then you got to keep your eye
on the nil money is that is that makes
sense does that is that what this is all
about right now
yeah but it's a lot more complicated
because you're kind of making it like
the nfl where here's your salary cap
there's not
there's not a cap and
nothing's on paper instead of like hey
here's your you know free agent contract
these schools just and some just say
okay hey you're going to get this here
and we've heard the stories that they
say that and then they don't get it so
now you see guys
more in the portal a year later because
they were promised these things they
didn't get them
and again
free agency you know who's going in the
free agency market and the nfl in sports
this one you got no idea and then they
every day here's new ones so we get off
the field and we get a report every day
oh here's four new guys that went in
today
so very strange and are these guys that
you are familiar with because you you
had them on a radar screen beforehand or
um
how do you assess when those names come
in whether it works for ole miss
football
lane we just have to watch them i mean
some you're familiar with but you still
got to watch what they've done since you
know
and
i mean then you have the strange imagine
that stretch we actually have
players that are on our roster
that went in the portal still playing
for us took official visits we have a
player that signed somewhere else
is going somewhere else but playing in
this game and practicing for us think
about that
okay so there's a current you're the
ravens you're the ravens and your middle
linebacker or whatever has already
signed next year to play for the
steelers as you're still playing
how do you coach somebody like that
you'd be really nice i guess
[Laughter]
because but really that's really how you
got a coach in general
um
you know
you do the old school way all the time
which we really don't do that anyway but
the old school coach is doing that way
like
you know you're just gonna have to know
you're gonna have a lot of kids leaving
and i'm not talking about the ones that
already signed just in general right so
um
so
again
you become free agents when your
contracts up in the in
in professional sports you can become a
free agent whenever you want so imagine
drafting rookies and in the first year
they're not liking how they're playing
your first round pick and then so they
can just leave
well i mean i'm trying to determine
whether you think this is good or not
you know because
i'm serious uh lane kiffin you're on the
rich eisen show because you know we saw
coaches leave you know you you have you
have
been in other places before and you know
and you would have every right to take
another job somewhere else if that is
something that you feel is good for you
your family or or whatever
it is
so
shouldn't kids have the same
ability right
100 percent it should just be
more thought out
you know to have windows so that you
know when they're leaving people can
watch them because
it's a great it should have happened and
they should have this
um just like coaches do
but there's no window and also they're
not advised like very well
so you have thousands of kids going in
the portals but there's not thousands of
spots for people to take so they're all
going in thinking oh i have all these
spots
but
there's gonna be hundreds of kids
sitting at home next year that gave up a
scholarship thinking they were gonna
have spots because of this portal and
how great it is
you know and then they're not
so let's wait let's wave a wand how do
you what would you do lane kiffin ole
miss football head coach what would you
do if i've made you now you're
congratulations you're now in charge so
what do you what thank you
i don't really want that like i was like
i just like complaining about the
problem i don't really have the answer
oh okay that's what i'm just wondering
like what i mean you got to put a window
like so okay they can only go in at
these times
and then um you know
and the nil should be
on a contract because these some of
these places
the day before signing are sitting here
saying oh come here you're gonna get 50
000 when you get here and the kid goes
okay yeah i sign
and then we hear the stories that they
get there and they don't see anything
so there should be a way that like it
can't like a free agent contract
hey you get to see the contract before
you go there
right and i know you said something
similar that after uh dion um
made a a huge coup in in getting hunter
to go to jackson state um
is that
were you referring to dion
by saying that on the same day about
players going past i actually no i
actually wasn't all i think i was i
wasn't
i was
talking about some other schools we
recruit against okay i won't name them
okay i just wanted to give you the floor
on that
i was not even i didn't even it had
nothing to do with that okay i'm just
tired of the stories you hear where
these
a school or two that i know very well
says to the kid you will get this when
you get here and then we then the kids
the coaches the parents are they're in
the portal a year later because they
didn't get anything
lane kiffin here on the rich eisen show
pound the table for matt corral for me
as i'm sure you're going to do for all
the nfl uh
scouts and the talent evaluation
community that i know you know so well
that's going to be looking at hand size
and
vertex jumps and tape and eyes and skies
over the next couple weeks and months
coach yeah i think he's a great player
tremendous kid sees the sees the field
really well great release different
release points um
i think hand size height like you know
that that has
become less important at the quarterback
position you know everybody was
enthralled years ago for the pro style
big huge you know we all want you know
people that look like carson palmer you
know and now that's changed and all the
way back to russell wilson you know like
where okay now because of the rpos and
the quick release and not worried about
throwing from the pocket so much you
know with heavier with deeper drops
guys that aren't that big i don't think
it's as much issue anymore
and you know he's uh uh um just been
terrific for you so um
a couple more questions for you elaine
kiffin here how's your dad how's he
doing what's going on with him good
thanks for asking he's welcome on our
staff and he's working i just walked by
him right before the interview
he's a defensive analyst
walk me through how his analysis goes
for you will you please give me some
give me some good stuff what's going on
i mean he's 81. so he's in there
as early as anybody you know um watching
film and
he's just unique i mean he's taking
notes and staff meetings he's just a
rare breed
yeah man i spoke to mauro the other day
you know he took the yukon job he's
saying his dad's giving him you know a
lot of two cents what is it what is it
like to get it from your dad
lane what's that like for you it's great
i don't get it as much anymore just
because i've been
you know he was on our staff at
tennessee usc fau here so i guess that's
four places now so
i've kind of heard most of it already
what do you mean you've heard most of it
what do
[Music]
i joke with him i said i've heard this
story before you know like he tends to
repeat himself a lot
of
our fourth job together
but that is that is uh that is pretty
amazing that's pretty cool um and so
i'll ask you this question uh i've asked
of so many other people who have been
through alabama i've asked it mostly of
quarterbacks what's the most angry you
ever made nick saban
lane kiffin what's the most you ever um
well one of them's documented on film
yeah in the game which was the end of
the game and everybody thinks
because we had a turnover at the end of
the game when the ball hit the receiver
in motion and he lost his mind on me
but really it was not at that play it
was actually when they scored
that next series so then the defense
gave up a touchdown so you went on the
defensive stats that's when i got yelled
at not actually when the ball hit the
receiver we turned it over it was when
the defense got scored on that's
actually when he lost his mind i mean he
called it a
ass chewing i guess is what he referred
to it in the press conference yes
that's i guess is that is that rat
poison for the staff is that what that
is or or what you know when it comes
down to that
no no that's not rat poison that's a
totally different category
i've i've messed up my silos i guess
then my last one for you would be uh
you'd be terrific to to to ask this of
uh if you're if you're willing to to
share your thoughts uh you've gone from
the pros to college uh what is your two
cents on urban meyer's um
uh early firing or at least before we
ever thought that would be possible in
jacksonville based on what you might uh
know or just your sense of
of um having been there and done that in
the nfl and then gone to college and
have those challenges for yourself yeah
i wouldn't be educated enough on what
happened there not following it with our
stuff going on and everything so
um i got no idea what happened there um
that that transition has worked a few
times a lot of times it doesn't work you
know you're
and i'm not saying this happened in that
one but you know you're dealing with
college players you know
versus professional athletes that
you know are making a lot of money it's
just a different
it's a different world
lane appreciate the time uh it's been uh
it's been too long uh i really
appreciate what uh what you're doing
down there in ole miss and um and always
shooting straight and i'd love to do
this more often if you're up for it so
thank you you you got it right
you too that's lane kiffin of ole miss
football right here on the rich eisen
show
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here